on Monday the streets of the Haitian
capital port-au-prince
were once again taken over by thousands
of demonstrators it's been three weeks
since the unrest began and protests
against the Haitian president show no
signs of letting down we are looking for
president you've no Moy's to put him in
jail because the Haitian people don't
recognize him as the President of Haiti
we've been fighting for so long but
things don't improve all the government
does is steel clashes between police and
demonstrators have become commonplace
so have attacks against private
businesses and police stations
[Music]
authorities have been accused of
excessive force using tear gas and live
ammunition to disperse demonstrators one
local journalist was shot during the
most recent unrest but over the past few
weeks the violence on the streets has
claimed several lives despite the police
standing in our way we're not afraid of
anything we will continue to do what we
have to do demonstrators blame Haiti's
president for a laundry list of problems
the country's plagued by double-digit
inflation currency devaluation and an
ongoing fuel shortage that's wreaked
havoc on public services an
international delegation of ambassadors
known as the core group are attempting
to mediate Haiti's ongoing political
crisis but opposition leaders are
unwilling to sit down for a national
dialogue saying the only thing that will
stop the unrest in the country is a
resignation of president Juvenal Maui's
officials say public schools and several
government services will remain shut
down until the unrest subsides but with
opposition leaders calling for more
protests no one really knows how long
that means my name is Apollo al-jazeera
port-au-prince